meagan Markel and Prince Harry are all
about that healthy West Coast lifestyle
I'm a California girl I think all those
hippy dippy things have been in my DNA
so probably since the womb and et is
learning that mmm healthy habits are
rubbing off on Harry a source tells ET
that the Duke of Sussex gradually
adopted a more plant-based diet of
organic foods after he started dating
Megan in 2016 I definitely try to eat as
clean as possible
just fish and veggies but I am also a
foodie so on the weekends all bets are
off
and get this Harry's also taking an
interest in the kitchen I love to cook
our source says that for Harry and Megan
part of living a normal life includes
cooking their own meals it's something
Megan's been doing for years she had her
own lifestyle blog the tig before
marrying Kerry I really do have a
organic and deep love of travel and a
food and and also of writing of my baby
so I'm very proud of it and who can
forget those Sussex is engagement and
that famous roast chicken cozy night
we're doing just roasting chicken and
chicken make an aunt a green la
lifestyle I think I've really rubbed off
on the Prince and for the better another
must for the couple is being close to
nature
I think it'd define a work a workout
routine that really speaks to you beyond
trying to get goals for your body a
source tells ET that being able to hike
with friends Archie and their dogs in
Canada is a simple pleasure that they
love adding not spending the holidays on
Vancouver Island costume Aiken and Harry
confirm that their decision to make a
royal exit was the right one trust that
the woman I chose as my wife upholds the
same values as I do
and she does
[Music]